what does anxiety feel like for you
control
um
i've often described myself as a loving
controller
right and that's not other people i
don't like controlling people i have no
intention of doing that it's more like
situations my brain will try and find
the worst case scenario
and then already figure out how to get
out of the worst case scenario before
the thing even starts i know yeah
i can understand that and then i'll be
like i don't want to be
caught with my like ass out i don't want
to be like because why i don't know why
like
those moments though when we do fall on
our face and
and and [ __ ] goes sideways and we don't
have control those are the most magical
moments so what what has that happened
when does that happen when have you fell
in your face when have you
i think it's why i love the stage i
think and
speaking specifically stage acting
versus film acting although i think it's
possible to find sometimes in film
acting with the right
circumstances that being said when you
start a play
a show
and the train leaves the station
and you're
whatever happens on stage happens
a light doesn't come you slip you fall
you're the props not there your partner
goes up like you know it just
it's so it's full improvisation
um which is probably why i love the job
i'm doing right now so much
the gemstones because these mother
suckers are incredible improvisers and
everything is just in the moment and
sometimes i find myself frustrated that
i i don't feel
i'm i feel like i feel like slow
in the um in their presence often
because it's like their brains are going
so fast because they're not trying to
figure out how not to
how to fix things they're just like
super in the moment
but it's great practice